[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a quick update video weekend edition
so my last video which a lot of you guys
watched and enjoyed was the mac pro
review video uh which involved turning
off the mac pro taking it out and
putting it front and center here on the
desk and that involved a lot of hours of
not using the mac pro because i was
shooting it uh so now that the mac pro
is back behind the scenes running the
show
it's pedaled to the middle here with a
lot more of the reviews and videos that
i was working on before i was reviewing
mac pro so now that's back in action and
of course there are a lot of other
reviews in the works and like i say this
and i've said this before but
trust me when i say there are many many
things that i have have had and haven't
had the chance to show on video yet so
the tab pro 8.4 is one of them the
massive here i'll show you the galaxy
note pro which is a 12.2 inch tablet
i've tweeted a teaser to this uh if you
follow me on twitter you're probably
aware of some of the other videos i have
in the works including the setup tour
project so the setup tour project while
i knew it was going to be a huge
undertaking getting all these people's
clips and collaborating them into one
massive video i didn't realize i would
get more than 1200 submissions so 1200
30 second video setup tours and i don't
know if you guys have ever edited a
thousand video clips before but it takes
a long time so i definitely have a
couple more days to go in that edit but
i've been working on it and i felt the
need to let you guys know where that
stands i should also mention that not
every video can make it in because 1230
second videos would be 10 hours
not just 10 hours of me watching them
but a 10 hour long setup tour project
would be way longer than last year's so
it'll be edited down and hopefully a
very concise but high quality fun to
watch project so expect that in a couple
more days i'll also be recording my full
setup tour video and uploading that
alongside the compilation video last
year i put them in one video but i'll
put them separate this year so yeah
that's kind of what i wanted to tell you
guys as far as what i'm working on uh
obviously mobile world congress mwc is
going on right now in barcelona spain
obviously i'm not there um
a lot you know to be honest a lot of
that is just people holding up the
device pressing the record button
ranting off the specs and then stopping
the video and moving on to the next one
and that's kind of not really what i do
i like to get a sense of what it's like
to actually own and use a device so uh
i'll be keeping my eye on mwc and if you
guys see some awesome stuff that's there
make sure to tweet it at me hit me up at
mkbhd on twitter let me know so i can
get those devices in this studio and
check them out and hopefully be able to
shoot a video on that for you guys and
also at mwc there's going to be a
samsung event and there's also a
satellite event right across the river
in new york so i'll be attending that
event where we'll hopefully be able to
see the galaxy s5 new watch uh galaxy
gear 2 galaxy gear 2 neo some stuff has
been leaked but really i'm hoping to get
hands on with the galaxy s5 for you guys
and show what that looks like but that's
tomorrow actually right after class so
i'll literally get out of class like
drop my backpack off here and go over to
the city to check that out so that's
also what's coming out all right random
faq one question i've gotten a lot is
when are you going to be shooting in
4k
a lot of people have been asking me that
this year uh right now 99 of the shots
you see on this channel especially in
the review videos are shot on a canon
eos c100
and uh that's a cinema camera that right
now shoots only 1080p
so my answer to when i will shoot 4k is
the instant that a canon cinema camera
is available that shoots 4k to internal
storage canon make it happen i've also
gotten a lot of questions about the skin
on the back of my nexus 5 because i
haven't actually said what it's called
other than putting it in the description
numerous times so this is the red carbon
fiber nexus 5 skin from dbrand inc i'll
again leave a link to that right below
that like button so if you want to check
it out for your own nexus you can
actually i didn't tell them that i was
ordering it but i i bought one i guess
they found it in their their system
whatever so they they figured out that i
that i ordered one in there they sent me
a uh an mkbhd edition uh skin for the
back of the nexus 5. they also sent an
mkbhd edition sticker for the athm 50s
headphones and the ps4 so they've got a
whole bunch of awesome skins going on
might be working with them on a giveaway
soon if you want to see that let me know
what that thumbs up or maybe a comment
below if you have any suggestions for
how we could structure that but an mkbhd
edition skin might be an interesting uh
fun theme for a giveaway so either way
that's about it for the update video
just want to give you guys a heads up
for what's on the way to your sub box
here on youtube uh if you're if you're
wondering like why has there been a
video in four days you think nothing's
been going on uh trust me there's been
quite a few things going on in the
background behind the scenes that that
aren't uploaded to youtube so if you
want to see more of the teaser stuff for
the behind the scenes stuff follow me on
twitter on instagram
and on google plus and
facebook if you want i don't really use
facebook that much but those are the
social networks where you can see more
stuff of what i'm working on and then
you'll see the final result boom
uploaded to youtube so that's been it
thank you guys for watching i'll catch
you guys very soon in the next one talk
to you later
peace
[Music]
you